I heard a great story about you that uh
Mick Jagger the greatest musician come
on the Rolling Stones that Mick Jagger
is a big fan of Curb Your Enthusiasm and
you were sitting in a restaurant and
some woman came over to you and says I
represent Mick Jagger blah blah blah he
loves you so much and we want you to fly
out to see Mick and you'll go backstage
and say hello to him and everything and
you said I love this you go I'm too busy
I I got [ __ ] to do I can't I got a show
to do tomorrow night I'm not going to
see Mick Jack I gotta work tomorrow yeah
how the [ __ ] do you fly to Ireland in
the spirit of the moment I say [ __ ] my
job yeah but being on set tomorrow I'm
going to Ireland to hang out with
exagger you know when I read about right
there yes when I read about [ __ ] like
that where you know rock stars they're
in their own Universe they can they can
fly to Ireland on a whim you know when
you're a working actor comedian you got
bills to pay you can't just pick up and
go to Ireland not Ireland [ __ ]
[Laughter]